Let's pray together over day 36, Holiness and
the Will.
Father, we give thanks to you today that you have given to us a will,
the opportunity to choose.
While our will was once bound in darkness and sin and
bondage to the slavery that it produces,
you have set us free by grace, and we rejoice in that.
Thank you for the freedom that we have to be like you
and to be built in your image, to be fashioned after your
image. You are a thinker, a feeler, and a
decider, and we have the same option, the same opportunity, and we
thank you for that.
Lord, I pray that you would help us today to
yield our will fully to you,
that there's nothing in our lives that would be held back
or pull back from your will and your way.
We ask, Lord, that like the songwriter said, that my will be in
perfect accord with thine own sovereign will, thy desires
to fulfill.
Lord, we pray that you would let that be so.
We pray that we would yield until our will was
taken up into yours, and that we would will
as you would will. Thank you, Lord Jesus, for showing us what it's
like to submit your will to the Father.
Thank you for demonstrating that submission to him,
and thank you for the Holy Spirit that speaks to us of
Jesus and isn't about his own will, but about the will
of the Godhead. We pray, Lord, that you would help us to
increase in our strength and willpower.
We pray, Lord, that our willpower would not be our own self gritting our
teeth, but instead you would help us to have an expectant faith
in the power and the ability of the Holy Spirit to give us self-control.
Thank you, Lord. We rest our face towards you.
We look our eyes towards you and Jesus, and we ask that you would
help us receive exactly what we have asked today.
Make us in our wills like Christ.
Let's continue praying together and seeking him.